Eucher's theory says that only the
numbers that are relatively prime to n
have multiplicative inverse not n.
So, what does relatively prime mean?
If x is relatively prime to n,
that means there is no common factor
between x and n other than 1.
For example, three is relatively
prime to 10 whereas two
is not relatively prime to 10.
For given n how many integers
are relatively prime to n?
This is measured as
a totient function of n.
How do we compute totient n?
If n is a prime number, then totient
n is n-1, because every number that's
smaller than n is also relatively primed
to n because n is prime number itself.
If n equal to p times q and p and
q are prime numbers, then totient
n is p minus 1 times q minus 1.
You can verify this easily on your own.
More generally, if n equals to p
times q and p and q are relatively
prime to each other, then totient
n is totient p times totient q.